supongamos que tenemos tres sillas los
voy a pintar por aquí nos va a poner
como espacios en blanco vale 1 2 y 3 y
ahora supongamos que tenemos 7 personas
a las personas las voy a llamar a b c d
e iván 5 f&g siete personas ok esas
siete personas queremos sentar las en
las sillas de cuantas formas podemos
hacer esto sí si nos importa en que sí
ya queda cada persona bueno pues vamos a
empezar a sentar los uno por uno va
entonces digamos vamos a empezar con la
silla número uno por decir algo pero
pudimos haber empezado con cualquiera
pero vasitos están parados de cuántas
formas podemos sentar una persona en la
silla uno pues tenemos siete personas
paradas y tenemos que queremos sentar
una entonces hay siete opciones verdad
voy a ponerle por aquí arriba que hay
siete posibilidades ok
ahora ya que hicimos que una persona se
sentará pues eso ya cancela una persona
parada entonces para cuando pasemos a la
silla 2 sólo nos quedan seis
posibilidades verdad es una menos que 7
aquí 6 va y de modo similar si ahorita
ya sentamos a dos personas pues nos
quedan a ver 7 menos 2 nos quedan 5
entonces quedan 5 posibilidades para la
silla 3 ahora fíjate para cada una de
las posibilidades de la silla 1 hay 6
posibilidades para la 2 y luego hay 5
posibilidades para la tercera de este
modo tenemos que multiplicar cuando
hacemos elecciones por separado tenemos
que multiplicar los números entonces el
número total de posibilidades es 7 por 6
por 5 y eso cuánto da haber 6 por 5 x 30
y luego 30 por 7 210 verdad entonces es
igual a 210 va eso de ahí es un montón
de posibilidades vamos a hacer un
ejemplo más pequeño para poder enlistar
las todas
ahora vamos a poner vasos digamos sí y
vasos porque no los voy a poner con otro
color entonces esto de aquí es un vaso
vaso uno estoy acá es el vaso 2
y en estos dos vasos queremos meter
pelotitas voy a poner una pelotita rosa
mexicano voy a meter una pelotita
naranja y voy a meter una pelotita
amarilla va ahora lo que quiero saber es
de cuántas formas podemos colocar estas
tres pelotitas en estos dos vasos de
nuevo que quede una pelotita en cada
vaso otra vez si no puesto ninguna
pelotita vamos a empezar ahora con el
vaso dos para que veas que no importa el
orden de cuántas formas puedo poner una
pelotita en este vaso está fácil si no
hemos puesto ninguna pelotita en ninguno
de los vasos pues tenemos tres
posibilidades de pelotitas para poner en
el vaso dos tres
y para cada una de estas tres
posibilidades cuántas se pueden poner en
el vaso 1 pues ya pusimos una en el vaso
y nos quedan 22 entonces sería 2 x 3 y
eso de ahí es igual a 6
vamos a intentar enlistar todas las
posibilidades vale creo que escribir las
pelotas con conocidos va a ser muy
difícil mejor déjame ponerles pues
digamos letras esta de aquí va a ser la
pelota a esta va a ser la pelota ve y
esta va a ser la pelota sí
entonces lo que quiero mostrarte es que
hay seis formas en las cuales estas tres
pelotitas pueden quedar en estos dos
vasos ok entonces lo voy a escribir así
voy a ponerle a ive lo que quiere decir
en el vaso 1 y ven el vaso 2 también
puede ser b ya fíjate que simplemente
intercambiamos las pelotitas de modo que
si nos importa cual pelota queda en cual
vaso luego nos queda a en el primero y c
en el segundo verdad o bien se en el
primero y en el segundo y quedan otras
dos las otras dos que quedan es be en el
primero y se en el segundo o bien se en
el primero y ve en el segundo vale ahora
fíjate que si no nos importará el orden
o bueno más bien si sólo nos importa
cuáles pelotas son las que quedan y no
en dónde quedan entonces tendríamos que
eliminar las posibilidades del segundo
renglón al hacer esto tendríamos la
mitad de posibilidades para colocar
estas pelotitas cuando si nos importa
dónde quedan las pelotitas por ejemplo
aquí arriba también nos importaba donde
quedaban en las sillas entonces le
llamamos a estas cosas permutaciones va
ahora vamos aquí arriba vámonos a un
poquito de notación entonces en la
primera pues nos estamos preguntando de
cuántas formas podemos sentar siete
personas entre sillas y si nos importa
en qué si ya quedan entonces eso lo
escribimos como 7 p
a penas de personas sedes de
permutaciones p3 esto también se puede
escribir como p
es o sea acomodar siete cosas en tres
espacios o bien para acomodar siete
cosas en tres espacios son tres
notaciones distintas para una misma cosa
ya vimos que esto es igual a 210 ok muy
bien y pues ahorita vamos acá abajo va
acá abajo como lo escribiríamos pues de
modo similar lo voy a escribir con otro
color de modo similar tenemos tres cosas
para colocar en dos espacios entonces lo
escribiríamos 3p dos o bien pe 32
o bien igual a pe de tres cosas en dos
espacios simplemente estoy escribiendo
anotaciones distintas eso es igual a
seis ahora vamos a ver si podemos
determinar una regla general para
encontrar las permutaciones para
encontrar no sé digamos las formas de
poner n cosas en cada espacios vale de
cuántas formas podemos poner en objetos
en cada espacios donde si nos importa en
qué espacio queda cada cosa entonces si
pensamos un poquito
pues a ver vamos a intentar hacer esto
por analogía vale entonces vamos a
dibujar 123 ta ta ta y así hasta acá
espacios ok entonces en el primer
espacio y digo por empezar en algún
lugar no pero en el primer lugar hay n
posibilidades justo como lo hicimos
antes hay n posibilidades
luego en el segundo espacio como ya
ocupamos una de uno de los objetos
entonces nos quedan n son posibilidades
después de eso en el tercer lugar hay
dos posibilidades y podemos seguir así
sucesivamente verdad y aquí tenemos que
concentrarnos un poquito para saber de
cuántas formas podemos sentar a alguien
o bueno poner algún objeto en el espacio
que puede saber aquí nos queda n menos
uno menos que el espacio que tenemos eso
suena un poco confuso pero a ver mira lo
voy a escribir nos quedaría n menos y
luego nos quedaría entre paréntesis k
menos uno va esto de aquí puede parecer
un poco complicado pero tiene todo el
sentido del mundo fíjate cuando hicimos
7 p
entonces lo que hacíamos era multiplicar
7 con 6 y luego multiplicarlo con 5
verdad entonces literalmente lo que
estábamos haciendo era poner los 3
números más grandotes desde 7 hasta 1 y
multiplicarlos es decir los tres números
más grandes de siete factorial entonces
nos queda 7 por 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 por
2 por 1 eso de ahí es 7 factorial y
simplemente tomamos los primeros 3
términos del factorial de modo similar
verdad 6 también es 3 factorial pero
otra forma de pensarlo es pensarlo como
tomar los primeros 2 términos de 3
factoriales para el otro además era un 1
verdad pero entonces lo que estamos
haciendo aquí abajo es tomar los
primeros términos de enee factorial lo
voy a escribir aquí abajo
los primeros k términos de n factorial
entonces ya tenemos una expresión por
escrito pero hay una fórmula que también
expresa eso mismo o sea o sea la fórmula
va a quedar bien fea pero fíjate nos
quedaría n factorial dividido entre y
aquí nos quedaría n
k factorial ba vamos a ver si eso de ahí
funciona
justo dividir entre eso es lo que hace
cancelar los otros términos del
factorial que no queremos va pero bueno
vamos al caso de arriba nos quedaba 7
por 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 uf y
luego dividimos entre nm factorial a ver
n 7 k era igual a 3 verdad entonces 7
menos 3 es igual a 4 entonces hay que
dividir entre 4 factorial 4 por 3 por 2
por 1 y por supuesto esto se cancela con
haber con otro color esto se cancela con
esto y justo obtenemos los primeros 3
los primeros tres factores de 7
factorial vale entonces pues bueno son
los los tres más grandes factores de 7
factoría y eso es justo lo que
casi siempre vuelvo a deducir esta
fórmula verdad porque aprenderse la no
tiene tanto chiste pero bueno fíjate
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
empezar el factorial nos queda 7 por 6
por 5 o bien aquí abajo pues es como 3
por 2 por 1 y pues así es más fácil
acordarse sin tener que acordarse de la
fórmula aquí abajo nos quedaría 3
factorial dividido entre 3 - 2 factorial
3 - 2 es 1
entonces nos quedaría factorial
factorial va a fuera verdad y eso de ahí
es igual a 3 por 2 por 1
dividido entre 1 porque uno es 1
factorial se cancela con el 1 y por
supuesto nos queda 2 por 3 que es igual
a 6 espero haber explicado bien esta
idea de las permutaciones para que le
vayas más o menos agarrando la onda
aprendes de la fórmula tiene su sentido
porque anoche en aquí va un paréntesis
tiene su sentido porque te ayuda un
poquito a ahorrar tiempo pero si te
acuerdas de estas ideas es muy fácil
reducirla simplemente hay que ir
pensando en espacios y poner poco a poco
cada uno de los objetos otra forma de
pensar los es como ya dijimos tomar los
primeros términos de n factorial estos
salen de ir descartando como acá arriba
nos queda 7 6 y 5 ya no queda más
espacio para colocar objetos
multiplicamos y listo es lo único que
nos dice esta fórmula
espero no haberte confundido y te veo en
el siguiente vídeo para hablar de
combinaciones